there's no end in sight to these
protests and the intensity the
confrontation along the Gaza Israel
border isn't lessening we filmed as
crowds ran towards waiting paramedics
metres from the front lines chaotic as
they carry the injured some a hit high
on the body and they're in terrible
shape
[Music]
everyone knows Israel will protect its
border but they still keep coming and
thousands have been hurt many end up in
clinics like this one run by medicine on
frontier in Gaza City it's quite
staggering really they're treating
hundreds of mainly young men every day
and as each week passes and after each
demonstration there are more there now
long-term injured the protests what
happens at the fence will change their
lives forever the injuries we see are
very difficult to treat so the risk of
not healing is very real and very high
so yes you have it we have a generation
of young men 24 years old who will not
be able to work believe
be fully functional anymore in the legs
who will have long-term consequences for
the rest of their life planned
demonstrations this week has been fueled
with anger by these pictures paramedics
walking forward to help the injured with
the hands in the air
before one of them as an al-najjar is
shot and fatally wounded the funeral of
the 21 year old volunteer in Khan Younis
brought thousands onto the street an
Israeli investigation won't quell the
anger it's guaranteed more
demonstrations and more violence well
certainly the protesters the last couple
of months have raised the whole issue of
Gaza in the eyes of the international
community but with over a hundred dead
and thousands injured you have to wonder
how much more can be achieved by these
protests especially if the political
leadership in both Israel and Gaza see
all of this through the prism of a
military conflict rather than a social
protest Israel hold Hamas responsible
for the demonstrations and the violence
Hamas blames Israel they warn that
without a relaxation of the economic
blockade here things will get worse
after Ramadan I think it will be a very
big wave otherwise if you if you in the
West find a solution for the people we
can within two months build a transient
seaport to allow our people to be
treated outside and to allow these the
social and financial aids to come
through this channel to be distributed
for the poor people I think it will
minimize it will is the state of
confrontation with well on the border
but if that will continue I think the
next wave will be more more more bloody
clearly negotiations about economic
blockade of Gaza and relations between
the vast majority of people in Gaza with
the State of Israel than needed but
there aren't any so it goes on and will
likely get worse
Stewart Ramsay Sky News Gaza